[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about things marvel
and
mcu we are in the final stretch
in the drought of marvel content yes
last week's
investor day was super awesome and a lot
of new content did drop but we haven't
had
anything actually released as far as a
show or movie is concerned
but we are in the end game now because
we have
less than a month now until the one
division series premieres on disney plus
and today we actually have some new
scenes to break down scenes that weren't
shown in the first trailer or the second
trailer that was shown during the
investor day
so the first new scene that we saw was
actually with wanda and vision with
their two twin boys now for those of you
who may not know
wand and vision do have twin boys in the
comics and they go on to become the
superheroes wiccan
and speed wiccan has powers like his
mother wanda and speed of course has
powers like his uncle
quicksilver now as they're holding their
twin boys in this scene it almost looks
like a scene from the brady bunch
and that's of course because it's
supposed to we know that wanda vision
itself
is supposed to be like a sitcom and
they're going to put wanda and vision
in other sitcoms that have aired
throughout life so this one it's the
brady bunch and they have their newborn
babies in their hands and there's more
important things to break down about the
two boys in just a second but let's go
on to
a new really great look at the comic
accurate costumes that wanda and vision
are going to be wearing at one point in
the series
wanda has on the classic scarlet witch
wardrobe she even has on the crown as
well
and vision's costume is actually kind of
funny because we know that they're going
to be wearing these comic accurate
costumes as
kind of a joke a little joke that marvel
threw in there because they're actually
dressing up for halloween with their
kids so they're taking their kids
trick-or-treating and what they're
dressing up as
is their comic versions of themselves so
that's a good little node and joke to
the comics there but it's kind of funny
to see vision wearing
high-waisted shorts as part of his
costume now back to their twin boys
wiccan and speed we know that they're
going to grow up
very quickly within the series and this
is because wanda and vision are going to
jump through different decades
we've seen each trailer and this leaked
tv spot now go from black and white to
color at one point in time
and that's because they're going through
different decades going further along in
time until they eventually end up in the
present time
but what does that mean for their kids
well we know that they're going to grow
up as well but we also know that this
reality that wanda and vision are in
isn't real they're actually in a bubble
reality in some town and sword is
actually monitoring them and is aware of
them
in the recent trailer that we got we
hear somebody on the radio somebody from
sword
possibly jimmy wu and we hear him say
wanda can you read me
who is doing this to you confirming that
she is in a different reality and it's
being manipulated not only by herself
but whoever put her inside of there
and it could be agatha harkness but in
the same trailer we actually
see her say are you here to help us now
this could be her talking to somebody
outside of the reality that she is stuck
in along with wanda and vision
or she's trying to trick them and she's
simply plain dumb but
if it isn't her it very well could be
mafesto in the comics wanda's kids are
actually the shards of mafesto soul and
eventually he takes them back and
wanda loses her kids and that could be
something that we kind of see happen in
the mcu in the series although they
won't take directly from the comics
it is definitely now confirmed by the
trailers that wanda is indeed in a
different
fake reality and unless she figures out
a way to transfer her kids from one
reality to another
they might not be there when it goes
away and in the comics this is what led
to the house of m
storyline which we know wanda vision is
going to be based off of as well
and in the series this could lead to her
blowing open the multiverse and that's
when she comes into doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness as well
but let me know what you think about
this do you think that it's agatha
hartness trapping her
in the reality or do you think it could
be mephisto let me know what you think
in the comments down below and let me
know what you thought about this leaked
tv spot
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a tony stark quantum suit funko
pop for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof